i am so excited for this series and i'm
curious what are you guys most excited
for people to see in the rings of power
there's been some incredible love care
and attention to detail put into the
show in every single aspect the costumes
the set design
um the performances
uh i'm really excited for people to see
the specificity of the detail and love
brought to life
i think newman i'm really excited about
like
i love the beginning where you see a
sildore refuse to throw the ring into
mount doom and
i'm really looking forward to people
seeing like it's silver and deal and
numenor their story yeah i love learning
about the behind the scenes the making
of a show what do you think would
surprise people to learn about the
making of this specific series
um i think what really surprised me um
was
the prosthetics team
um like we were really lucky that
the orcs are all um practical
um and all sorts of surprises the fact
that that means that you're getting in
there at 7am being like gosh it's so
early and the orcs have been there since
half midnight and getting their
prosthetics put on
it is incredible it's really frightening
i feel like really lucky that we got to
actually be terrified by very nice
people but in prosthetics yeah and then
got to see them eating lunch
yeah and i'd i'd say the simplicity of
some of the things um yeah in such a
vast production in such a vast world um
the simplicity of
some of the processes there were parts
when we were on the raft and there would
be occasions when we'd
have huge wind machines and wave
machines going and other times when it
would just be guys with buckets of water
throwing the water at us because
the wind machines make too much noise
yeah yeah sometimes simple's best
without spoilers do you have what's your
favorite of the eight episodes and why
i think the first episode has a special
place for me um because you're being
reintroduced to middle earth and middle
earth at a different time
and i think also just in terms of us
filming we had to stop filming the first
episode
um
because of the pandemic and coming back
we loads of us thought we wouldn't
necessarily get come back to film and
coming back to film it was just so
wonderful so i think the first episode
for me
i'm gonna say the opposite i'm gonna say
the last episode the eighth episode
uh but i'm not gonna say why i'm gonna
leave uh
a few
details you know unexplored a lot of
your fellow cast have said episodes six
and seven so i'm very curious about
seven but anyway um when you think back
on the
lord of the rings the original trilogy
do you have a favorite moment from those
films
yes it's when aragorn comes through the
doors at helms deep
and that had like a profound effect on
her sexy
um
yeah i'd say mine is in the fellowship
when um the hobbits have just left the
shire and they're being chased by the
ring rates and they're hiding under the
road under that
um
where the roots are so scary i've just
so i was quite young when i first
watched that and i found that bit
terrifying and always lingered with me
actually though like it's not a slowly
favorite but probably one that's had the
biggest effect to me is that i can't
like eat a cherry tomato without
oh you have dinosaurs
yeah the tomatoes the singing yeah i
want to switch to the southern seas and
filming that specific sequence did you
do any sort of advanced training to be
able to be in that tank um and you know
film that sequence or sequences yeah we
did lots of training with amazing people
yeah some amazing people at the top of
their game that were yeah train we had
trent bray who's a really accomplished
swimmer um
that that taught us to properly swim i
think which was pretty amazing um
yeah yeah dive instructors yeah we had
we we learned to free dive um
to spend a bunch of time underwater
which was a grueling difficult
challenging process but uh
the payoff was
you know i hopefully it'll show in the
show but yeah we wouldn't have been able
to do what we did without that training
yeah
um
i think that's the water stuff and then
we did it i mean we did a lot of stunt
training and fight training which all
bled into yeah the work we do in the
raft i will say actually motivate is
much uh
more balanced than me on the raft there
was a lot of on the waves i i would fall
over quite a lot and fall through the
cracks in the right
ever actually fell off no which is yeah
like
that's good another way of going back on
it yeah
and one of the dops fell off their um
paddle board oh yeah that was funny so
not everyone came away lots of hazards
out there yeah what did it actually mean
to both of you to bring this location to
life for the first time in any sort of
lord of the rings you know project we
were really excited about that the whole
time yeah um
because you don't spend much time in the
ocean yeah right in other adaptations
um and i find water really frightening
which is why i was quite scared before
the dive training because like
it's the unknown
um
and
i felt really lucky as well that we
actually because of the way they did it
all practically it felt like i did
actually experience the sundering seas
yeah exactly that we spent and we spent
so long because it was such a complex
sequence we spent
weeks and weeks out there in two two
different locations as well in a big
outdoor tank and then in a five meter
deep
dive tank um
so yeah it's it's really exciting to i
guess explore the oceans of
of arda of the areas around middle earth
between middle earth and numenor what
can you actually tease about the
relationship between your two characters
in that sequence
um
i think it's two people who
meet so by chance yeah and like gladreal
is
a legend of middle earth even though
she's
not even she's got thousands of years
left to live and she's already legendary
um
and hal is incredibly normal it's just a
dude yeah just a middle earth dude
like their meeting
shouldn't have happened but i think when
they meet from hal's perspective he
knows there's something special about
galadriel um
and i won't divulge if he knows exactly
who he is who she is um
i i have a decision on that but i think
it's best left ambiguous um
but yeah i
i think from his perspective she brings
out some things in him and and
illuminate some things in his mind that
he hasn't necessarily considered things
about his own life and his own past as
they get to know each other a bit more
but certainly when they first meet i
think he's quite standoffish and um
distrusting of her is there anything
about the scene
that uh tests them specifically i'm sort
of hinting at is there anything below
the water that is testing them
hypothetically
well i think for galadriel as well
though she's an elf alone
um
so it's above the water as well they're
surrounded by humans
yeah exactly and there are certainly
dangers in
in the sundering seas so
they're tested physically and mentally i
think at that point in the story for
for hal certainly and i think for
galadriel is that it's an
it's a moment of survival they have to
survive and they end up using each other
to survive one of the things i thought
was cool about the the pictures is that
the tank was built uh like on a back lot
and you had natural sunlight coming in
to to illuminate the two of you and i
know looking at vfx shots when it's all
fake light it looks terrible but i would
imagine that it's gonna look amazing
what what what was it like filming in
natural light it was cool it was pretty
it was pretty amazing particularly in in
the harsh new zealand sun which is great
i ended up you know you you would it
would be challenging by the end of the
day because you're outside and it's so
glary and you're surrounded
by sort of like a backdrop i think which
was white so it reflects a lot um
but
it was a it was a pretty spectacular
place to film the tank was so vast it
was huge and it did give you that
feeling of particularly when you're
you're plonked on this raft and pushed
out into the middle of it and you're
actually quite far from the rest of the
crew you do feel isolated yeah and
because it was so big
you could suspend your just believe that
it kept on going yeah
yes it was really cool on that note i
need to stop i sincerely mean it when i
say i cannot wait to see the series and
um and talk to you when i've actually
seen episodes you know what i mean right
yeah yeah oh lovely to meet you
thank you so much thanks for your time